que hace que llegue una mujer como
presidenta a un país como honduras
quisiera decirle que es que somos una
sociedad avanzada que la mujer se ha
empoderado pero lo cierto es que será en
la coyuntura de la situación del
cansancio del pueblo hondureño sobre lo
que es incorrecto en el manejo de la
cosa pública la corrupción profunda que
se dio y la esperanza del cambio que
genera una mujer le ha dado el triunfo
contundente al mandato en el poder
ejecutivo la presidenta trans lo hace
sea o no
[Música]
partidario de ello tiene méritos muy
muy destacados como son el hecho de ser
una mujer de carácter de lucha y que
estaba siendo la candidata de un partido
que ha venido luchando en las calles
señalando la corrupción insoportable que
sostuvieron durante 12 años el otro
partido político del partido nacional
así que sobre el machismo que es
preponderante en nuestro país que que
siempre busca menospreciar lo que es una
realidad la mujer hondureñas es más
constituye más del 51% de los votantes y
de las y en general de los habitantes
lo cierto es que ella ha logrado
sobreponerse a eso con el ofrecimiento
de cambio de reconciliación y en la
polarización que se dio en estas
elecciones entre los que estuvieron
estos 11 años y lo que es posible hacer
más adelante ganó sin lugar sin lugar a
dudas con la mayor legitimidad que era
posible